hello I'm Donna Friesen after months of
being told to stay inside to keep our
distance from other people now we're
watching hundreds of thousands of people
gather on the streets to protest police
brutality and racial injustice making an
already deadly situation more complex
these protests the outrage the calls for
justice would be extraordinary at any
point in American history that they're
happening in the middle of a pandemic in
a country that has the most cases and
the most deaths from Kovach 19 makes
this moment exceptional it's never
happened before the spread of an
invisible virus and the very visible
death of an unarmed black man pinned to
the ground for almost nine minutes by a
white police officer has led to an
intersection of two of the biggest
challenges our society has faced health
care workers who were cheered on for
their courage now cheering on protesters
who demand that black lives matter a
public health crisis that's killing
people converging with racial inequality
that's killing people too black
Americans make up roughly 13% of the
population yet available data shows they
account for close to 25 percent of
overall Kovan 19 deaths in the US and in
some counties close to 60% how does that
compare with Canada no one knows
governments here don't collect go
mid-nineteen data based on race and
socio-economic background that is
starting to change because what doesn't
get measured doesn't get addressed
there's a gap in data collection that
advocates say could paint a more fulsome
picture of disparities in Canada and
allow for evidence-based decisions on
how to shape future policy that remedies
in justices with me to explore this
further as dr. onion no room she's a
family doctor a public health and
preventive medicine specialist she's the
associate program director of the public
health and preventive medicine residency
program at the University of Toronto dr.
Norman thanks for speaking with us today
let me ask you first as a public health
specialist when you see all of these
people out on the streets in close
contact in the middle of a pandemic
knowing the novel coronavirus has not
gone away how much does it concern you I
think the fact that people are willing
to go out and speak about human rights
issues even though that they know that
there is a cove at 19 pandemic but they
feel that
passionately about it I think deeply
moves me in fact I think overall is the
public health position I can say that it
is important as you know dr. Teresa Tam
and others said to wear personal
protective equipment so wearing a mask
using sanitizer but what I see as a
black woman and physician is people
coming together to address a major issue
that we have in Canada which is anti
black racism which is in fact been
contributing to worse health outcomes
for black people for century an anti
black racism traces back to our history
of slavery of having segregation here
but also just a series of issues around
community injustice Canada is not the
United States we do have a different
history here we like to pride ourselves
on tolerance and diversity as a black
woman and a black physician explain to
us your experience your lived experience
in this country and working as a doctor
in this country my lived experience and
born and raised in Montreal so that's
where I'm originally from living in
Toronto now as a child I experienced
racism you know in the schoolyard being
called the n-word and things like that
but what I think was most painful is
where teachers made assumptions about my
intelligence at a very young age and I
saw it happen you know time and time
again to my classmate so that's what I
grew up seeing and then becoming
position and then looking at the data
from 1996 to 2006 in Montreal a black
person with a graduate degree had pretty
much the same unemployment rate as a non
black high school dropout I live
I saw the people who went and got an
education did everything that they
needed to do to advance and live that
Canadian dream and be denied
opportunities and I saw the impact that
it had on my ears on young people seeing
you know our parents are telling us to
go to school but they're not getting the
opportunities and so you know now when I
look at the research and the data and I
see how across so many factors that
affect health whether it's income or
it's education or it's our labor force
that people of African descent are
denied opportunities really just based
on the color of our skin even despite
education what is really painful is that
the United Nations flagged that in
Canada institutionalized anti black
racism is an issue here they flagged
that in 2017 so it's not just my opinion
it has actually been demonstrated to
research who report and even with the
United Nations expressing their grave
concern for people of African descent
here in Canada so when you hear people
say that there is no systemic racism in
Canada what do you think when you hear
that well I think it's akin to where you
might have people who are of a dominant
group so let's say men think they don't
think there is any sexism when you're a
part of the group that is discriminated
against you are most likely to know
where there is discrimination I think in
Canada we have that denial we aspire to
that dream of you know a multicultural
society where everybody has equal
opportunity and I think it would be
beautiful if we get there I think we all
aspire to that but we have to face the
fact that we are not there so we can
take the right steps to get there you're
president of the black physicians of
Ontario you also train public health
officials what's the biggest
misperception among the public and
public officials about the connection
between background racial background
ethnic background and health outcomes I
think there are a few but I think that
one of the biggest ones that exists in
medicine is assuming
that race and genetics are tied together
so that where you do see differences
between race so let the rates of
hypertension one would it presumes that
it's due to and to genetic differences
but in fact we know that there's no
genetic or biological differences
between the races race is a social
construct that is used to create social
barriers and stressors that then impact
health so the concept of race is only
real insofar that we as a society
categorize people that way and treat
people based on that but it is not
biological let's talk about race-based
data we don't collect it in Canada
though some cities are now starting to
do that you believe it is vital can you
explain why we're cold in nineteen but
even Cryer Cove in nineteen to be able
to take the appropriate measures to
address health issues you need a clear
picture of what's going on at a
population level so that's kind of
standard public health approach so
that's why we collect information on
gender or where people live sometimes
it's their postal code just to get a
sense of you know risk factors things
that make people more vulnerable the
other reason that you want to collect
the data is that if you do have an
intervention if you put resources
towards prevention or addressing an
issue you want to know that it is
actually improved and is working on the
other hand for a lot of racialized and
including indigenous communities there
is a certain amount of mistrust with
having you know government leaders
collect this information and interpret
it in a way that can sting the thais
communities so we know that in Canada
lots of data has been collected on
indigenous communities and used to
stigmatize them we know that in the
United States lots of data has been used
in describing African American
communities and used to stigmatize and
pathologize that to make it seem like
something is wrong with that community
instead of something's wrong with the
society that put the community in that
situation that's why there's been a
hesitancy to collect it race-based data
yes on both ends so I think for some
people not knowing what to do or not
wanting to deal with the console
quences of understanding what the racial
disparities are and then also
communities being concerned that it
would be used against them so on both
ends and so my position is aligned with
the Canadian Public Health Association
in which they have recommended the
culturally safe collection of race-based
data so that again it's not just about
how do we fix these communities but it's
like how do we address the factors in
society that that led to certain
communities being predisposed to to
having higher rate of koban 19:00
infection